it was a moment of joy in Abidjan
supporters of former President Laurent
Gbagbo were watching the ICC decision
[Music]
back both supporters and members of his
FBI party feel as if they've been
vindicated but the old divisions in the
country haven't healed yet his acquittal
concerns the whole of the Ivory Coast
because today we must look ahead for the
country that's why we're saying Ivory
Coast first it was precisely this slogan
Ivory Coast first that contributed to
post electoral violence and bloodshed in
2010 and 2011 the Gbagbo camp had
alleged that the current president
Alassane Ouattara wasn't of ivorian
descent the lawyers representing the
current government at the ICC are
skeptical that the decision to acquit
Gbagbo will bring reconciliation to the
Ivory Coast three and a half thousand
deaths and no one is guilty that's going
to be unbelievable for the Ivorian
people and also for the international
community the wife of Laurent Gbagbo
herself pardoned by President waterer
says the country needs to forget for its
own good
pardoning isn't a luxury pardoning is a
necessity for the Ivory Coast everyone
should understand whatever their
political party ethnicity or religion
they need to understand and all the
national and international political
players should also understand this if
the country does not succeed in
pardoning past acts and is not able to
achieve reconciliation this country will
explode this country will disappear it
is everyone's duty and everyone's
responsibility
speculation has already begun that
Laurent Gbagbo will run in the 2020
presidential election
[Music]
[Applause]
you